honey he's saying local politics really
affect you yeah like that's that's
something that really changes your life
you but the day-to-day happenings of the
white house most of it is just your
fixating on these things that really are
probably never gonna have any impact but
local local stuff who's the mayor that
has a direct impact on your life what
are they gonna do with the streets well
it's not only the impact it's like how
much power do you have to affect change
at the local level a lot right White
House level very little yeah and we're
seeing that which is we're really one of
the really fascinating things about
Trump being president is how much he's
trying to do and how much he's not able
to do and how much pushback there is and
how much he is able to do and how much
outrage there is about it how much chaos
is surrounding the whole situation yeah
it's fascinating to watch all the the
the safe the checks and balances and the
safety procedures that are sort of built
into the system of government act out
and now that like you see the Senate
controlled by the Republicans and the
house controlled by the Democrats like
oh Jesus this is what I was hoping for
chaos as much chaos as possible the
shitshow and is gonna be more of a [ __ ]
show in the house with trying to pick
Pelosi x' number two yeah well and also
do you see that Trump was saying nice
things about Pelosi hilarious I know
it's that woman she does a great job I
think she really loves our country know
did you see what she said he goes she
deserves to be Speaker and if the
Democrats won't vote for her will throw
her Republican votes Wow he said that I
tweeted out it's just like I'm just
gonna press some buttons and see what
happens they all freak out it's amazing
it really is funny you know what I
thought it was really hilarious and I
actually enjoyed it when Alec Baldwin
got arrested and they said to Trump you
know Alec Baldwin got arrested with how
do you feel you go I wish him luck and
you know how I tweeted out of guy I bet
you CNN is gonna say Trump refuses to
denounce the violence in his hometown
[Laughter]
that's true I mean the but the fact that
he's like I wish him luck I mean yeah
look he just knocked a home run out into
the parking lot and smashed every window
and the cars parked up
yeah I mean with baldly getting arrested
for punching someone after all those
years of him mocking him on CN NS it on
and Senate live its but it's the Trump
curse like everyone who goes after him
you know they end up getting destroyed
like Ruth Bader Ginsburg I mean she just
fell and broke three of her hips I hope
she gets that's a curse it's a Trump be
the old lady just falls down no but
these the timing of these things are so
perfect and so like hilariously perfect
what about stormy Daniels like now you
got to pay his legal fees like that is
kind of hilarious
yeah that she's got to pay his legal
fees you know how much strip and you got
to do to pay those legal fees his
language his legal fees must be through
of the worst roof they're probably
millions of dollars yeah yeah I'm yeah
it's gotten crazy yeah he's charged it
up right sure yeah I mean he has an
enormous legal team they've been and
then how about all these people they
were gonna turn him like Michael Cohen
now he's [ __ ] yeah what is he gonna do
now what is he gonna say yeah well we
already know that you paid her off and
now no one cares right because he just
won the case right and so she has to pay
his legal fees and now you're stuck with
nothing you ain't nothing right and no
he oh he's trying to say a trump saying
Trump used racist language with me it's
like really okay well there's supposedly
that Mike Mark Burnett tape okay
yeah Tom Hartman Tom Arnold's trying to
find this right that's what Mark Burnett
the guy is it Mark Burnett yeah the
survivor guy depressed he's apparently
very religious okay and he is inclined
to support Trump's positions on many
things and he's just not gonna release
that no no there's no way Oh Trump who's
running a TV show we look at t look at
megyn kelly join Reid he's if he's using
racial slurs in front of cameras and a
cast of 50 which I'm sure gonna have
people of color this is New York there's
no way this wouldn't have leaked at the
time that's not true if he's using the
n-word that's not true
no if there's if there is a there's a
sound guy and there's a producer and
they're collecting tapes and everyone
has know if he's doing this publicly in
front of all he's not doing it publicly
he's talking to someone and it was
recorded much like the Billy Bush thing
when he was on the bus right it's kind
of doing it publicly but he's talking to
someone
I thought he's talking to when the cast
members supposedly that's not what I
heard okay well I this tape is what you
think foot yeah it is it's like it's
more
hangar 18 but it the other thing is if
he's using this language he would have
been using it frequently he doesn't hit
certain words over and over yes but it
could be he used it in a very specific
way like you know the story about the
guy from Netflix right or how about the
story about The Hobbit John Pappajohn
yeah that's outrageous well explain it
to people that don't know the story well
it's kind of a twist on that conference
call with a PR firm with a PR firm and
he said he was saying we're not gonna be
like Colonel Sanders saying blah blah
blah with the N word yeah and he was
quoting somebody else as an example yes
don't use this kind of speech it's
really bad and they go oh you invoked
that word you're fired literally and he
is the CEO of the company and he's
saying to them we're not gonna use these
words we're not gonna be like these
persons like it's not like saying
Michael Richards like hey like if I said
that like hey I'm not gonna be like
Michael Richards and get on stage in
front of everybody and drops men bombs
right and people just started freaking
out Joe Rogan just said the n-word yeah
and then all of a sudden that becomes
public and then I get fired and then
YouTube pulls me off and then iTunes
pulls me off literally that's what it's
like what happened with the Papa John's
yes all anybody hears is the Papa John's
guy said racist [ __ ] no no it's all to
hear all they heard was Papa John's
refused to support Colin Kaepernick and
now they're like all right we're gonna
get this [ __ ] and they did that's part
of it too right yeah that's part of it
too yeah